>> Stephen: WELL, THAT'S IT
FOR TONIGHT'S "REPORT."
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THAT'S IT
FOR THE 2014 MIDTERMS, BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THAT'S IT
FOR MY YEARS OF LIVE ELECTION
COVERAGE.
SO, I'D LIKE TO TAKE A BRIEF
MOMENT BEFORE WE GO TO SAY THANK
YOU.
AND ALSO THANK ME.
(LAUGHTER)
COUNTING MY TIME ON THE DAILY
SHOW WITH JON DAILY AND THE
DAILY ZOO CREW, WE'VE BEEN
GETTING TOGETHER WITH YOU LIKE
THIS SINCE 2000.
WHO CAN FORGET THAT
ONE? BUSH V CHAD.
IF YOU'RE COUNTING, THAT'S 8
LIVE ELECTION SHOWS IN 14 YEARS.
MAKES SENSE SINCE 14
DIVIDED BY 2 IS 8.
(LAUGHTER)
I HAVE SO MANY MEMORIES. MOSTLY
SHAPES AND COLORS.
THERE'S BEEN A FAIR AMOUNT OF
DRINKING ALONG THE WAY.
(LAUGHTER)
AS I LEAVE YOU FOR THE LAST
TIME, I'D LIKE TO SHARE WHAT
I'VE LEARNED WITH FUTURE
GENERATIONS AS WELL AS THE
ALIENS FROM ZAFRAX-5 WHO FIND
THIS SHOW ON THE GOLDEN
CYLINDERS LAUNCHED INTO SPACE
MOMENTS BEFORE THE EARTH
EXPLODES.
HI GUYS!
PLEASE REMEMBER THAT WHOEVER WON
THIS ELECTION, THE REPUBLICANS,
SOMEONE IS ALWAYS RUNNING
AGAINST SOMEONE SOMEWHERE
ELSE OR OTHER.
ONE OF THEM WINS, THE OTHER
LOSES.
SOME ARE TOO CLOSE TO CALL. YOU
MEAN TO CHECK BACK LATER
AND FIND OUT WHO WON. BUT YOU
FORGET AND BY THE TIME YOU
THINK TO DO IT, THERE'S ALREADY
ANOTHER ELECTION.
I'M SURE THEY WRITE DOWN WHO THE
GOVERNOR OF NORTH DAKOTA IS
SOMEWHERE.
I COULDN'T FIND IT.
BUT MOST OF US AREN'T GOING TO
NEED THAT INFORMATION.
WE GO ABOUT OUR LIVES SECURE IN
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT NORTH DAKOTA
HAS A GOVERNOR OR EQUIVALENT.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I'LL ALWAYS
REMEMBER?
THE HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
OF BROADCAST NEWS WHO TOLD US
WHO WON THAT GOVERNOR'S RACE.
MEN AND WOMEN LIKE -- STEPHEN
COLBERT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU SEE, FOLKS,
TONIGHT MARKS A SORT OF FAREWELL
FOR ME.
MAYBE SOME DAY YOU WILL SEE ME
ON TV AGAIN AND YOU WILL NUDGE
YOUR SPOUSE AND SAY, HEY, I
REMEMBER THAT GUY.
I USED TO LOVE HIM.
MAYBE I WILL BUY HIS SLAP CHOP.
SO THAT'S IT FOR "THE REPORT."
I'LL END BY SAYING IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE AND PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
BEEN WELCOMED INTO YOUR HOME
THESE LAST NINE YEARS.
SO TO YOU AND YOURS, I'LL SAY A
FOND -- WHAT'S THAT?
ANOTHER MONTH AND A HALF OF
SHOWS?
(LAUGHTER)
WELL, THEN, THIS WAS A LITTLE
TOO DRAMATIC.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M SORRY.
I'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW!
I'M EMBARRASSED!
WOW!